اعلن الجيش في النيجر تاييده لمجموعه
الحرس الرئاسيه التي اطاحت برئيس البلاد
محمد بازون وحذر مما سماه عواقب وقيمه لاي
تدخل عسكري كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي السياقات التي
قادت الى وقوع انقلاب عسكريا في النيجر
كيف ستتعاطى واشنطن وموسكو والدول
الافريقيه المجاوره مع نتائج هذا الانقلاب
ما هي المسارات التي يمكن ان تاخذها
الاوضاع في غربي ووسط افريقيا على ضوء
صراع المصالح المحتدم بين القوى الدوليه
الكبرى
المعهد الامور
التي
حاولت الدول غرب افريقيا ان تعطي اشارات
تنبيه ومبكره كانت توقع عن هذه المؤشرات
التي ظهرت
بحصوله احتمال حصول انقلاب عسكري كان
ينبغي معالجتها منذ زمن بعيد طبعا هذه
كانت حكومه جاءت الى السلطه عن طريق
صناديق الاقتراع والان
فجرت طاح بها رصاص للطلقات ان هناك دائما
[موسيقى]
تقليد او تكتيكات او اساليب لتقليد ما
قامت به دول اخرى اعتقد كان هذا افضل
الوقت بالنسبه للعسكريين ليقوموا بمقام
ابوه في النيجر لانه بدعم من دول مثل
بوركينا فاسو ومالي نحن نتحدث عن سياسات
داخليه في النيجر ولنتحدث عن تنافس القوى
الكبرى وطبعا لا نتحدث عن سوء اداره
الاموال العامه ان حكومه بازون كانت شريكا
وطيدا مع واشنطن وباريس وبروكسيل وكانت
حكومه جيده تحصل على مساعدات في مجال
التنميه وفي المجالات الماليه واذا ما كان
الجيش يعارض كل هذه الامور وطبعا من
الواضح انهم يعرضون ذلك ها هم ياتون
بتبريرات للاطاحه بالحكومه الامر يرتبط
بالسياسات الخاصه سياسات القبليه الداخليه
في النيجر
روسيا تنطلق من مباديها من مبادئ السياسه
الخارجيه الروسيه الروسيه تقول انها هي ضد
التدخل في الشونه الداخليه فلذلك في مصر
هذه الحالات روسيا دائما تاخذ هذا الموقف
السبب الرئيسي لهذا الانقلاب هو بطبيعه
الحال
العامل الداخلي الاسباب الداخليه والوضع
الاقتصادي ولكن مع ذلك يجب ان نعترف انه
هناك نوع من التاثير من الجوار
الجوستراتيجي غير
المستقر وايضا لابد من القول ان تصادف هذا
الانقلاب مع قمه روسيا افريقيا في سانت
بيتر سبورت لا يدل ان هناك اي علاقه
مباشره بين امرين هناك امكانيه لا يعرفها
بالضبط لحد الان ان حول ان اي
يمكن ان نقبل هذه الانقلاب العسكريه ان
ينظموا اليها او ينحازوا اليها الجيش
اسلام السلطه من الحكومه وانتخبه
الديمقراطيه التي كانت فرنسا تدعمها فهناك
احتمال كبير ان اخر معقل معقل لفرنسا في
افريقيا الفانكفورنيا قد ضعها من يدها
وبالتالي نعم هذه اخبار سيئه لفرنسا ولكن
لا نعرف الواقع بشكل مؤكد من الذي سيحل
محلها ومن سياتي هل ساعدتكم فرصه لروسيا
للتدخل والتعزيز
تواجدها في في ظهوريه النيجر ولكن ايضا
هناك لاعب كبير جدا في في النيجر وهناك
قدراتك عسكريه كبيره وبالتالي من سابق
لاوانه ان نعرف بالحقيقه اعتقد انا واشنطن
سوف تستخدم اوراق الضغط
حول ما يحصل
فان يجري بنسبه الى روسيا هي بمثابه غيمه
بلا مطر لا تستفيدوا روسيا كثيرا من
التركيز على هذا البلد ولكن انطلاقا من
مبدا النديه يمكنها لروسيا ان تتدخل
وتدعم الحكومه التي
ستكون في السلطه في هذا البلد ربما سيكون
هناك تكرار سيناريو مالي وسيناريو
الافريقيا الوسط اعتقد ان التحدي
للدول هو انه عندما نشاهد انقلابا يكون
هناك عزله دبلوماسيه وعقوبات واجراءات
عقابيه في البلدان المختلفه واعتقد انه ما
رايناه في السابق لم نتبع هذه المعادله
وبالتالي القاده الذين قادوا هذا الانقلاب
لا يخشون التبعات ولذلك
هنا في انتهاء نفس السلوك وبالتالي واشنطن
وباريس في موقف صعب يحاولون فيه ان يسلط
الضوء على اهميه قيم الديمقراطيه على
الامد البعيد وفي المدى القريب الامن في
هذه البلدان ما يتعلق بجانب الامني حتى
روسيا عليها ان تتصرف بحذر كبير نظرا
للوضع الذي
يواجهات ما يسمى بالتمرد لاقامه
على روسيا ان تستطيع ان تعيد التفاوض اذا
ما ارادت ان تصلح مصدر ثقه بالنسبه للدول
الافريقيه وان تعتبر المنظر اليها كشريك
امني